paris ville de lumière éblouissante de
beauté est aussi une ville dont les sous
sol regorge d'histoires mystérieuses des
mystères que nous allons dévoiler au fur
et à mesure d'une visite labyrinthique
qui vont nous conduire des catacombes re
secret des sources
puis dans l'antre des bunkers et des
carrières
débutons notre parcours dans le 14e
arrondissement et partons à la
découverte du plus célèbre des ossuaires
situé place denfert rochereau
celle que l'on appelle les catacombes
renferme aussi bien des pages de notre
histoire que des superstitions
alors avant d'arriver dans l'ossuaire à
proprement parler les visiteurs
parcourent un certain nombre de galeries
telle que celle ci où l'on voit une
inscription avenue de montsouris
toutes ces galeries que vont parcourir
le visiteur avant et après le suaire
sont des galeries de servitude qui ont
été créés par l'inspection générale des
carrières à partir de la fin du xviiie
siècle à partir de 1777
et pour que les ouvriers puissent se
repérer le nom de la rue qui était au
dessus a été gravée en dessous et 7
avenue de montsouris existe toujours au
dessus mais s'appelle maintenant avenue
rené coty donc les visiteurs parcourent
déjà à peu près 600 mètres de galeries
de servitude qui circulent à l'aplomb
des rues de surface ce trait noir
avaient été tracées pour guider les
visiteurs de l'entrée de l'entrée en
surface jusqu'à l'entrée des catacombes
ceci afin que les visiteurs ne s'égare
pas puisqu'il faut savoir que nous
sommes dans un parcours ouvert à la
visite qui fait à peu près on va dire 1
km 500 km 6 ans mais tout autour il ya
150 kilomètres de galeries donc il
fallait éviter effectivement que les
visiteurs ne s'égare en suivant ce fil
d'ariane nous arrivons donc dans ce
vestibule ce vestibule c'est l'entrée de
l'ossuaire à proprement parler cet
ossuaire ça a été un ossuaire général
pour la ville de paris qui a été créée à
partir de 1786 et de 1786 à 1814
on a vidé tous les cimetières parisiens
qu'il peut y avoir à proximité des
églises
le premier cimetière qui a été transféré
dans les ossements ont été transférés
ici c'est le cimetière des saints
innocents qui se trouvait au niveau des
halles mais il ya un certain nombre de
dépôt de semences du cimetière des
innocents qui ont été réalisés dans
l'est les catacombes puisqu'il faut
savoir que ce cimetière des saints
innocents a servi de cimetière depuis
l'origine de paris jusqu'au xviiie
siècle donc on peut considérer qu'il ya
eu deux millénaires de d'inhumation dans
ce cimetière des saints innocents et on
pense que il ya dû y avoir à peu près de
2 millions d'individus inhumé dans le
cimetière et ces transferts ont pris à
peu près une quinzaine de mois sachant
qu'il se faisait la nuit la nuit les
ossements étaient déposés sur des sur
des charrettes recouvert d'un drap noir
le la procession était suivi par des
prêtres qui chantent l office des morts
et ces ossements étaient apportées au
niveau d'un puits qui était rude
avenue de montsouris et il faut imaginer
qu'au milieu de ce puits pendant une
chaîne parce que comme les ossements
étaient vides et ombre par tombereaux il
pouvait arriver que c'est à ce moment
s'entremêlent et reste bloqué et donc
l'ouvrier qui étaient en bas secoué la
chaîne pour arriver à décoincer les
ossements daily mirror il devait pas
être sous le puits au moment où les
ossements se décoincer donc c'est parce
puis que les ossements des 6 millions
d'individus sont arrivés dans les
catacombes de paris et 6 millions
d'individus ce n'est pas rien c'est
trois fois la population de paris
actuellement c'est à ce moment là est
rangé rassemblés par par origine rangée
on verra des décors qui vont être qu'ils
vont être aménagés c'est à dire on a
fait des ags avec des ossements l'ont
donc l'effet miauler tibia et péroné
on a fait des frises de crâne pour
décorer donc sur trois étages et on a
jeté par derrière tous les autres
d'ossements du squelette que soient les
omoplates les petits hall et les os
cassés
nous
nous voyons un coeur fait avec des
crânes ce qui pourrait paraître morbide
en fait c'est purement romantique au
maccabi il faut ne faut pas oublier que
c'est notre civilisation hygiéniste qui
a un tabou maintenant vis-à-vis de la
mort alors que au xviiie siècle 19e
siècle les morts les morts et les
vivants se côtoyaient j'allais dire sans
aucun problème ce beau tonneau est en
fait un simple amoncellement de
d'ossements autour d'un pilier qui est
au milieu du tonneau donc c'est un décor
particulier mais nous sommes dans ce qui
s'appelle la rotonde des tibias et c'est
ici que le 2 avril 1897 a été organisé
un concert clandestins concert
clandestins pour lesquels une invitation
très officielle avait été lancée puisque
dans ce concert allait être jouée par
exemple la marche funèbre la la danse
macabre allait être récité des poésies
macabre enfin romantique au macabre donc
il faut imaginer que dans cette place il
y avait des centaines de personnes
le décor était un peu différent mais il
y avait des centaines de personnes qui
s'étaient installées pour assister à ce
concert clandestins en avril 1897
cette coupe elle est l'un des plus
anciens monuments qui a été édifiée dans
ce qui allait devenir l'ossuaire sur
cette coupe l on entretenait un feu en
permanence et ce feu permettait à l'air
de circuler et ça permettait d' assainir
l'air des catacombes parce que ces
terres étaient qualifiés de méphitique
de délétère et donc il fallait assurer
une aération force et donc c'est le
premier monument qui se conçoit qu'il a
fallu créer dans l'est dans les
catacombes sachant qu'auparavant pour
assainir l'air et faire circuler ses
terres au niveau de la de la maçonnerie
depuis qu'ils remontaient en surface on
avait en chasser des des boulots de
bouteilles avec le côté bouchons côté
extérieur du puits et en fonction de
l'air qu'on voulait faire rentrer dans
l'est dans les catacombes ont débouché
les bouchons de ces goulots pour forcer
l'air à rentrer dans le dans l'ossuaire
ce monument en forme d'hôtel est plus
qu'un qu'un monument
il faut savoir que la plupart des
monuments que l'on voit dans l'ossuaire
sont des consolidations qui ont été
faites pour renforcer le ciel des
carrières il y avait une forme d'hôtels
dont la sculpter ici on a utilisé toute
cette partie pour organiser des messes
dans les catacombes et ses messes dans
les catacombes était organisée le jour
des morts c'est à dire le lendemain de
la toussaint et ses messes ont duré
jusque dans les années 1975 1976
d'où de part et d'autre des sièges qui
sont effectivement des sièges sur
lesquels les enfants de choeur
s'asseyait pendant l'office dans toute
la partie aux sueurs nous allons voir
deux types de l'inscription gravée des
inscriptions telles que celle ci qui
indique la provenance des ossements donc
ici sont des ossements qui proviennent
de l'église saint nicolas des champs où
nous voyons qu'ils sont arrivés en
septembre 1859 et le deuxième type de
plat grave et ce seront des plaques sur
lequel sont gravées des 100 ans issus de
la littérature profane religieuse qui
rappelle la vacuité du passage de
l'homme sur la terre
nous
et
plus
le
dans les partis qui ne sont pas ouvertes
au public les asthmes en ce sens
effectivement en vrac puisqu'on n'a pas
fait ce décor puisque le public n'était
pas invitée à venir dans ces galeries
donc on a pas on a vraiment on voit tous
les ossements en vrac on n'a pas cette
vague d'eau selon qui retient les os qui
a derrière on n'a pas fait le décor ici
se trouve la plus grande profondeur
d'ossements on avait jusqu'à 30 mètres
de galeries remplit doucement
donc on voit encore un peu sur les côtés
du pilier que le ce n'est pas uniquement
un petit parement avec un mètre d'eau
semant derrière que par un bois il peut
y avoir plusieurs dizaines de mètres dos
en voici un autre monument qui est aussi
comme pour l'hôtel une consolidation à
laquelle on a donné une forme
particulière cette consolidation comme
on lui a donné une forme de sarcophages
et que sur cette consolidation ont
aggravé cette strophe du poème gilbert
ce monument est maintenant qualifié de
tombeaux de gilbert mais c'est un
tombeau vide
en tout cas qui est plein de calcaire
puisque c'est une consolidation gilbert
cet impôt est que plus personne ne
connaît bien évidemment c'est un poète
qui est mort en 1780 et qui est mort à
29 ans on ne sait pas trop si c'est
d'une chute de cheval ou de ou d'une
rixe mais toujours est il que il est
tombé en désuétude très très rapidement
comme la plupart des poètes que l'on a
dont on va voir des des strophes gravé
dans l'ossuaire plus personne ne sait de
nos jours qui sont ces poètes il faut
faire des recherches historiques pour
retrouver ce qu'ils ont pu écrire et
voici par exemple qu'une une descendance
qui est issu de la littérature ainsi
tout passe sur la terre esprit beauté
grâce talents tels une flotte elle est
une fleur effet manière que renverse le
moindre vent nous poursuivons notre
voyage souterrain dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris à hauteur du
célèbre pont de l'alma
prochain arrêt les égouts de paris
l'autre jour à paris donc de 1400
kilomètres d'égouts entièrement
visitable en service la particularité le
réseau et gravitaire et unitaire une
terre ça veut dire qu'on collecte les
eaux de pluie en même temps que les eaux
usées en provenance des habitations
le réseau est suffisamment vaste pour
accueillir toutes sortes de
canalisations la galerie fait office de
galerie technique
nous accueillons donc l'eau potable par
ces canalisations nous acheminons
environ 700 mille mètres cubes d'eau
potable sur paris 1 pour alimenter la
capitale à l'eau potable est constitué à
50 60 % hautes sources le restant c'est
l'eau de la seine et de la marne qui a
été potabilisée et a ajouté à ses autres
sources
nous avons un réseau d'eau non potable
qui sert à alimenter les bouches de
lavage pour les balayeurs le l'eau qui
coule dans les caniveaux est en
provenance de ce réseau d'eau potable et
nous avons un système de nettoyage
automatique des égouts qui fonctionne
aussi avec cet os ici vous avez un
ancien raison pneumatiques en fait qui
servait entre l'assemblée le journal
officiel et le sénat en fait
les comment les hommes politiques en
fait après après avoir délibéré faisait
circuler des messages dans des petites
fusées en fait les textes de loi allait
se faire imprimer au journal officiel
par ce réseau ça s'est arrêté en 2003
maintenant il fonctionne avec des
messagerie sécurisée
nous avons dernièrement la fibre optique
en fait qui s'est installée on voit le
petit ami si envoûtant il y en a
énormément dans notre réseau donc par
cette fibre optique transitent toutes
sortes d'informations informatique les
chaînes câblées internet à haut débit
tout ça passe par ses septs petit câble
alors nous sommes ici devant un égout
élémentaire en fait le premier la
hiérarchie de nos ouvrages en a trois
types d'ouvragés donc les goûts
élémentaire il est situé
il est située au point le plus haut
directement sous la chaussée
cet égout en fait entendre se déverse
dans un collecteur secondaire qui est le
2ème deuxième ouvrage dans la hiérarchie
qui lui-même va se déverser dans un
collecteur principal situé au point le
plus bas
l'histoire de l'eau à paris c'était cool
et au fil des siècles
nous l'avons vu de nombreux chantiers
ont été mises en oeuvre dès le moyen âge
pour faire entrer l'eau dans les maisons
les ego de la capitale ont connu une
histoire parallèle
savoir que les romains nous avez appris
beaucoup de choses malheureusement les
rois de france n'ont pas su entretenir
ce savoir tout ça s'est perdu un petit
peu au fil des siècles ce qui fait qu
arriver au début du 19ème la situation
était catastrophique à paris le
l'empereur napoléon iii en fait a réagi
a chargé le préfet haussmann d'assainir
la ville est lui-même a fait appel à
l'ingénieur eugène belgrand qui s'était
déjà distingué lorsqu'il était préfet de
l'yonne
j'aime belgrand avait créé un réseau
d'irrigation très sophistiqués pour
l'époque sont la ville d'avalon et tout
naturellement osman a fait appel à cet
homme de génie pour améliorer les les
conditions d'assainissement de la ville
de paris alors avant belgrand au début
du 19ème il y avait en tout et pour tout
26 km d'égouts à paris lui il a été
appelé à la rescousse en fait il y avait
de gros soucis d'assainissement il faut
savoir qu'on buvait l'eau de la seine
l'eau de la seine était complètement
pollué parce que après consommation de
cette eau ont rejeté tout dans les rues
et par ruissellement en fait les eaux
polluées rejoignez le fleuve
donc on buvait un peu à peu nous
extrêmement donc tous les 10 20 ans on
avait une épidémie de peste le choléra
c'est épouvantable à chaque fois c'était
dix vingt mille morts donc les jeunes
belgrand est appelée au milieu du 19e en
1854 il a été nommé le service de l'eau
de paris dans un premier temps il va
s'attacher aux problèmes de
l'approvisionnement en eau des parisiens
il va acheminer l'eau potable en grande
quantité pour alimenter la capitale pour
éviter ces c
c'est pollution du fleuve et éviter ces
catastrophes sanitaires
après il va donc s'intéresser au
problème de l'assainissement il va
concevoir un réseau très ambitieux pour
les potes
alors pour se repérer en égout nous
avons les mêmes plaques en surface en
fait nous nous nous dirigeons de cette
manière nous retrouvons donc les les
mêmes plaques en surface mais aussi les
numéros d i mode qui correspondent aux
branchements grâce à un petit peu plus
loin alors dans un égout élémentaire ces
détails standard les le point le plus
haut c'est de mettre 30 da hauteur et 1
m 30 au point le plus large
on retrouve toujours les deux
canalisations eau potable pour les
riverains
oh non potable pour nos systèmes de
lavage automatique
et pour la petite vanne balayeur en
surface on va pénétrer dans les ouvrages
voilà là nous sommes devant les goûts
élémentaire de la rue cognacq jay chou
voyez que dans la pratique un lego est
beaucoup plus sale on retrouve aussi
souple et toutes les canalisations les
câbles qui encombrent habituellement nos
ouvrages
on voit ici il ya beaucoup de fibres
optiques beaucoup de câbles qui passent
à cet endroit
après notre visite du musée des égouts
de paris
nous avons eu la chance de pouvoir
suivre une équipe d'égoutiers partis
inspecter un réseau sous la rue de
l'amiral moucher
régulièrement des équipes d'égoutiers
partent en mission d'inspection
le réseau parisien est aujourd'hui
équipée des meilleures technologies afin
d'assurer le bon fonctionnement de la
collecte des eaux usées
mon
là nous sommes sous une bouche d'égout
en fait la traditionnelle petite fente
dans le caniveau c'est par là que
s'engouffre les autres pluie et tous les
détritus en fait qui se trouve sur la
chaussée en fait atterrissent dans les
égouts de cette manière c'est pour cette
raison qu'il faut constamment entretenir
ces bouches d'égout il faut éviter
qu'elle se bouche pour éviter les
problèmes en surface notamment des
grandes mares d'eau sur les chaussées
qui vont convoquer des carambolages de
l'aquaplaning et aussi des inondations
pour les commerces de plain pied alors
des bouches d'égout il y en a dix huit
mille à paris elles sont situées aux
angles au carrefour en fait aux angles
de rues
la principale tâche des égoutiers en
fait c'est de nettoyer constamment les
ouvrages
il faut savoir qu'un réseau d'égout si
on l'entretient pas il va très vite
s'ensabler en fait c'est là le sable en
provenance des rues départ qu'en fait
ils tombent dans l'eau d'ouvragé pour
nettoyer les égouts en fait belgrand
n'avait pas beaucoup de solution ne
pouvait pas utiliser d'électricité pas
de moteur thermique on se serait
asphyxiés dans les réseaux dont il a eu
l'idée d'utiliser l'eau usée matière
qu'on avait en grande quantité dans les
égouts il a créé des outils sous forme
d'un barrage mobile en fait on dépliait
cette partie le matin appelé l est et on
faisait ce qu'on appelle monter le plan
d'eau en fait ont retenu est toutes les
eaux en provenance des habitations
quand nous avions suffisamment d'eau
usée à l'arrière une réserve d'énergie
donc suffisante
on faisait jaillir cette eau par le
clapet par la réduction de diamètre
l'eau jaillissait sous pression et
chassait bas tout ce qui nous encombre
est le sable et cailloux
puisqu'il y en provenance de la rue en
fait tous les les encombrants alors on
le déplace vers des bassins de
dessablement le bassin de dessablement
c'est un bac décanteur en fait à une
fausse plus large plus profonde que les
goûts et le sable va venir se piéger
dans cette fosse une fois c'est ce
bassin c'est complètement rempli on va
envoyer des hommes avec des camions
aspiratrice pour qu'on fait ça semble
lors de leur tournée d'inspection du
réseau les agents d'assainissement ou
égoutiers sont non seulement chargés de
détecter la moindre anomalie du réseau
mais aussi d'assurer l'entretien la
surveillance le curage et le nettoyage
dudit réseau
viens de vous l'expliquer notre expert
le métier des gauthier est un métier non
seulement éprouvant mais risqué
les agents parcours donc des kilomètres
sous terre à l'affût de la moindre
obstruction ou de la moindre altération
des galeries
donc on travaille comme consiste à
donner toutes les informations aux chefs
et ils nous demandent son état vent
divin c'est bon ya pas de dégradation
apparente et pas de fuites d'eau donc on
lira ici et on va continuer comme ça on
est face au numéro 72 qui correspond à
la surface c'est ce qu'on appelle un
branchement en particulier celles roger
légaux j'avais l'alimentation d'eau
potable qui alimente le bâtiment qui au
droit donné goût en surface on peut plus
bas vous avez sont rangés ici donc nous
nous présentons l'accès à l'égout alors
nous avons trente mille regards d'accès
en fait pour accéder dans nos ouvrages
pour des raisons de sécurité il y en a
un tous les 50 mètres ce qui nous permet
d'évacuer très rapidement en cas de
danger des dangers il y en a plusieurs
notamment la présence de gaz toxiques
nous nous sommes protégés par ce petit
appareil c'est un détecteur de gaz ce
qui nous intéresse le plus en fait
détecter l'hydrogène sulfuré communément
appelée h2s alors c'est un gaz qui se
fabrique dans les matières en
décomposition très dangereux pour
l'homme
quasiment une odeur il aurait soi-disant
une odeur d'oeuf pourri très difficile à
détecter dans la puanteur ambiante en
fait donc en cas de présence de
dagenais sans trop forte concentration
l'appareil va sonner vibrer aussi ce qui
nous ce qui nous prévient et nous
évacuons très rapidement les ouvrages en
cas d'orage très violent on peut être
emporté par les eaux dans dans les
grands ouvrages donc les égoutiers de
paris ne descendent jamais sans laisser
un agent surface généralement c'est un
ancien il connaît très bien le réseau
il faut savoir que l'état qui vole qui
en sous sol ça ne fonctionne pas les
téléphones portables non plus ce n'est
pas la peine d'essayer de nous contacter
quand on quand on travaille le seul
moyen en fait c'est à l'aide du marteau
trappe aux frappes de cette manière sur
la fonte ça résonne en égout alors on
communique aussi comme ça on a un
système de de code en fait si on tape
deux fois c'est le l'homme d'au-dessus
qui veut être remplacé un besoin
pressant ou où il a besoin d'être
remplacés en fait si on tape trois fois
c'est quelqu'un du service en fait il ya
besoin de voir le chef d'equipe et si on
tape de façon ininterrompue ça veut dire
si un danger est là toute l'équipe iii
montrent très rapidement pour évacuer la
loi après une descente dans l'enfer de
l'odorat notre voyage dans les sous sol
parisien continue par le 19e
arrondissement non loin de la place des
faits dans un monument connu sous le nom
de regard de la lanterne
vous vous trouvez dans le regard de la
lanterne c'est un petit monument assez
curieux et très peu connu du public qui
se trouve au milieu des tours de la
place des fêtes
la paris dans le 19e c'est un bâtiment
qui a été construit à la fin du xvième
et au début du xviie siècle et qui est
classée monument historique depuis 1899
mais ils restent généralement totalement
fermé au public à l'exception des
journées du patrimoine ou bon an mal an
au cours des deux journées nous arrivons
à recevoir environ 1500 personnes dans
ce regard
oh
la glotte de belleville c'était un des
réseaux de captage qui étaient au nombre
de quatre ou cinq qui jalonnaient les
ses collines ses collines de belleville
c'est l'extrémité nord-ouest du grand
plateau de romainville qui termine en
arc de cercle qui surplombe les 19e et
20e arrondissements de paris est aussi
coté romainville pré saint gervais et
toutes ces zones ont été l'objet de
captage d'eau depuis le moyen-âge la
particularité géologique de ces collines
c'est de contenir dans leur sous-sol
deux couches imperméables dans la partie
supérieure une couche qu'on appelle les
marnais à huîtres et un peu plus
profondément les des gloss verte et à
l'époque où les captages était en pleine
activité il faut imaginer ces collines
pratiquement vierge de toute
construction
l'eau de pluie s'infiltrer dans le
sous-sol et formaient des nappes sur ces
des nappes aquifères sur ces couches
imperméables et c'est naples
leur trop-plein ressortait on petit
ruisseau sur le flanc des collines
davantage de ces collines c'était de se
trouver à faible distance de paris est
suffisamment en altitude
puisque le sommet et n'est pas très loin
du regard de la lanterne à la rue du
télégraphe à 128 mètres cinquante lots
pouvait couler par gravité sans le
besoin de pompe dont on ne maîtrisait
par la technique à cette époque elle
pouvait alimenter les fontaines qui ont
commencé à fleurir sur la rive droite de
paris à partir de la fin du xiième
siècle le regard de la lanterne
c'est un bâtiment qui abritait en fait
un puits que vous voyez ici un puits qui
est à peu près d'un mètre cinquante de
profondeur et qui reçoit les eaux de la
nappe qui se trouve juste au sud et
marne à huîtres dans la couche de sable
de fontainebleau on l'appelle l'eau des
sables et en plus de cet apport elles
recevaient les captages de trois pierres
et vous voyez les pires et qui
arrivaient ici qui remontait à peu près
à quelques dizaines de mètres de part et
d'autre du regard alors lors sortait en
surverse pour pénétrer dans la grande
galerie de l'aqueduc et elle s'est coulé
dans la petite rigole au centre de la
galerie que l'on appelle la cunette et
les deux parties plates les deux
trottoirs de part type d'autres
s'appelle normalement des banquettes et
c'était là que circulaient les gens qui
faisaient l'inspection du réseau le
l'aqueduc de belleville lui-même
existait déjà au xiiie siècle
on a retrouvé sa dans les archives le
par contre le regard
ici est un bâtiment qui a été construit
à la fin du xvième siècle et comme vous
le voyez sur cette plaque qui a été
posée le jour de l'inauguration en 1613
il est indiqué que les travaux ont
commencé en 1583 et se sont terminées en
difficile d'imaginer qu'elle a dû être
le labeur de ces hommes qui des
décennies durant se sont relayés sous
terre pour apporter l'eau à des
populations alors dépourvu de tout
confort
non
tous ces captages ont été regroupés plus
tard sous le vocable source du nord dont
du nord de paris par opposition aux
sources du midi les sources du sud qui
constitue l aqueduc d'arcueil qui
apportait les autres agissent sur la
rive gauche mais seulement à partir du
début du xviie siècle
l'importance des sources du nord c'est
qu'elles ont été la seule alimentation
en eau des fontaines de paris depuis la
fin du xiième siècle jusqu'au début du
xviie siècle
justement à l'époque où l'on a eu le
complément de l'aqueduc d'arcueil et
ensuite des premières pompes qui ont été
installées directement sur la scène
c'est donc un maillon extrêmement
important dans l'histoire de
l'alimentation en eau de la ville de
paris
l'eau fut un enjeu fondamental dans
l'histoire de france on peut noter par
exemple en 1806 napoléon décrète que
l'eau doit désormais couler sans
discontinuer dans la capitale
à dire lorsqu'on passe une rivière une
vallée les arches comme un recueil on
appelle ça l'aqueduc d'arcueil mais la
partie souterraine se fait plus partie
de l'aqueduc en fait si tout l'ensemble
constitue là que duke pour le regard de
tête du réseau municipal
on a fait un effort particulier et vous
pouvez admirer ce ce bâtiment qui était
il faut bien le voir complètement perdu
dans la campagne soigneusement fermée à
clé et que personne ne visite est jamais
à l'exception des fontainiers et du
prévôt des marchands une fois par an
avec l'échevin qui était en charge des
fontaines qui venaient faire une visite
pour voir si tout allait bien dans les
réseaux d'alimentation en eau des
fontaines de paris la coupole qui
recouvre ce regard est surmonté d'un
petit élément architectural que l'on
appelle généralement un lanterneau ou
une lanterne
d'où leur le nom du regard le regard de
la lanterne alors cette lanterne
elle était destinée d'abord à laisser
entrer la lumière et ensuite à aérer
l'eau dans des regards généralement il y
avait toujours une soeur une aération
suffisante pour bien aéré loki qui
transitaient par par ces bâtiments
alors tous les regards avaient chacun un
nom des noms qui provenait soin de leurs
caractéristiques architecturales comme
c'est le cas ici où souvent des fois le
nom du propriétaire du terrain sur
lequel ils se trouvaient l'aqueduc du
pré saint gervais et celui de belleville
réunit tous les deux ça donnait en
moyenne 400 mètres cubes d'eau et par
jour donc c'était très très faible si
l'on comparé à la population de l'époque
à paris ça faisait une moyenne d'environ
2 litres par jour et par habitant
donc les gens continuaient largement à
s'alimenter comme auparavant
au zoo de la scène et aux eaux des puits
domestiques mais pour alimenter les
fontaines il fallait une eau qui coule
en gravité qu'ils soient un peu plus
élevé que le niveau des fontaines
elle-même et c'est pourquoi ces eaux ont
été les seuls à pouvoir alimenter les
fontaines pendant près de cinq siècles
de plus leurs qualités n'étaient pas
extraordinaires comme on l'a dit c'était
des eaux d'infiltration et en
particulier les eaux captées au niveau
de la couche la plus profonde ne
baignait dans une couche de calcaire
qu'on appelle les calcaires de bris et
cette eau était assez impropre à la
consommation à la cuisson des légumes la
lessive
elle ne prenait pas le savon comme on
disait il était très chargée en selle de
calcium et de magnésium
c'est ce qu'on appelle une eau très dur
on nous trouvons maintenant un présence
du regard saint martin alors les
religieux de saint martin des champs
tout comme les religieux de saint lazare
qui avait capté des eaux sur les
collines du côté du pré saint gervais à
la fin du 12e
ces religieux de saint martin des champs
vraisemblablement à la même époque ont
établi un réseau particulier pour leur
abbaye
oh
comme vous le voyez les eaux de sa vie
arrivé dans le regard par
l'intermédiaire d'une petite galerie
moins grande que la galerie de l'aqueduc
de belleville mais qui faisait à
l'origine environ 135 m il n'en reste
actuellement qu'une quinzaine de mètres
accessible puisque les fondations de
l'immeuble qui se trouve derrière ont
interrompu la conduite
donc les eaux tombe par cette petite
boule autre revêtue de plomb d'ailleurs
dans ce petit bassin de décantation
elle tombe par surverse et à partir de
la rue des cascades
elles partent dans une conduite qui
allait jusqu'au temps puisse se dire à
quelques kilomètres soit d'ici au temple
et à saint martin des champs
maintenant nous sommes descendus dans le
regard qui s'appelle le regard des
cascades
donc comme vous avez vu nous sommes
descendus par un tampon style tampon
d'égout qui est disposé à même le
trottoir alors c'est pour cela que l'on
l'a construit ces marches
ça permettait de casser le flot d'eau
qui était assez important et en même
temps d'aérer l'eau l'eau coulait donc
sur ces marche comme sur des cascades et
c'est ce qui a donné le nom au regard le
regard des cascades qui par la suite a
donné son nom à la rue elle même puisque
la rue des cascades s'appelle ainsi à
cause de la présence du regard des
cascades et non pas parce qu'il y avait
des petites cascades dans la rue comme
on a souvent tendance à le dire et
d'ailleurs cette rue sur les plans
anciens s'appelait lassante des monnaies
la construction de galeries souterraines
de puits de captage et de canaux se
succéderont au fil des siècles et
témoins aujourd'hui du défi qu'il aura
fallu relever pour faire entrer l'eau
dans nos maisons
nous avons cette fois rendez-vous gare
de l'est dans le 6e arrondissement de
paris les entrailles de la gare cache un
témoin de notre histoire
le bunker de la gare de l'est
au printemps 1915 les allemands sont les
premiers à se lancer dans l'utilisation
de gaz comme arme de guerre
les conséquences seront désastreuses et
vont tellement marqué les esprits des
soldats et du gouvernement français que
des mesures seront prises pour anticiper
une nouvelle attaque de ce genre
le bunker de la gare de l'est et donc
construit en 1936 afin de protéger le
personnel de gare et l'armée d'une
attaque au gaz
ce graphique de gestion des trains
montre que même pendant la guerre le
bunker et la gare ont poursuivi leur
activité
le bunker fut occupée pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale par l'armée allemande
après guerre il revint à la france et
les inscriptions en allemand gravé dans
les murs furent soigneusement dissimulé
ces restes d'inscription sont les seuls
témoins de l'occupation allemande entre
1939 et 1945
aucun document ni témoignages ne laisse
à penser que la gare de l'est et jouer
un rôle prépondérant pendant cette
triste période on a néanmoins découvert
des papiers photographies mettant en
scène la gare sous l'occupation
on voit par exemple sur cette
photographie le ministre allemand de la
communication parler devant ses troupes
à l'endroit même où les passagers se
pressent aujourd'hui dans l'attentât tgv
ou d'un train de banlieue
non
oh
cet autre document a été retrouvé un
matin de commémoration il est daté du 8
février 1943
voici ce qu'on peut y lire
monsieur vous êtes tenu de vous
présenter au trinquet quittera la gare
de l'est à destination de l'allemagne
le 16 février 1943 à 15 heures vous
devez vous munir au préalable du
certificat dans bausch qui est tenue à
votre disposition au bureau d'embauché
de votre employeur
si vous ne vous présentez pas au départ
du train ou si vous abandonnez le train
en cours de route
des sanctions seront prises contre vous
ce document a été écrit sous l'autorité
du commandant fans grosse à paris à
l'attention de monsieur vers stappen
alphonse
bon
c'est important l'histoire qui a pu se
passer et comment les gens plus la vie
est ce que c'est ce que moi j'essaie de
faire le pas au métier de communicant
c'est de trouver les iphone info qui
permet d'avoir un peu l'histoire de ce
qui s'est passé mais c'est vrai aussi
que qu'il faut que les gens se retire de
10 dès que les trains d'apporter son
parti d'ici qui serait d'autant plus
attristant vis-à-vis de nous qui
travaillons tous les jours
par contre les déportés sont revenus
gare de l'est on a des images avec la
croix rouge qui était présente
et là c'est un grand bonheur ce fut un
grand meneur pour eux et c'est quand
même plus de wii fit pour nous d'avoir
ce côté d'histoire quand même
dans le hall de la gare de l'est à paris
en présence de personnalités du
gouvernement des syndicats de la
fédération nationale des cheminots et du
directeur général de la sncf a lieu une
manifestation à la mémoire des victimes
de la guerre
dans un silence recueilli la première
plaque voit les deux tricolores et
découvertes
elle rappelle le départ forcé des
martyrs de la déportation allemande
non
la seconde plaque commémore le retour
des prisonniers les rescapés des bagnes
d'outre-rhin retour tant attendu par des
milliers de familles françaises dont
beaucoup n'ont pas eu la joie de
retrouver les kocher à jamais disparu
dans un bunker
il n'y a pas d' échanges physiques avec
l'extérieur on pourrait comparer cet
édifice à un sous marin
la mise en place d'un système de
ventilation a donc été nécessaire pour
permettre l'arrivée d'air et
l'étanchéité du bâtiment
ce système fonctionne en cycle fermé
avec un vélo qui actionne la ventilation
à travers un absorbeur de co2
ce système permet de préserver l'air
dans cet espace et ange ces vélos sont
d'origine et fonctionne encore au cas où
le système de ventilation automatique
tomberait subitement en panne
démonstration
c'est un très bel exercice je pense
qu'effectivement il faudra qu'on n'ouvre
le bon coeur tous les matins aux agents
bien pédaler un peu et ceci permettrait
de perdre quelques kilos tous ces
systèmes de manette qui permettait
d'ouvrir fermer les vannes le pourquoi
justement de cette minorité qui explique
aussi la construction des brokers
m
non
là on a on à son train téléphoniques ont
les mêmes où on a effectivement les
sorties publiques et réseaux internes
dans ce qu est ce qui est quand même
intéressant il a quand même tout près du
corps est encore quelques temps le
téléphone moderne a bien numéro se
laisse donc on se disait matin c'est
bien s'il a un problème il appelle mais
il a été décodé
on était obligé de faire de la place
dans nos réseaux de téléphonie pour
alimenter d'autres raisons a pu
téléphone est important ne place pas le
bunker de la gare de l'est garde bien
des secrets sur son histoire
mais en parcourant ce lieu chargé
d'émotion on devine les hommes qui ont
traversé ces couloirs et les guerres
notre parcours s'achève dans le 14e
arrondissement sous l'hôpital cochin
après une longue descente
nous découvrons les carrières de la
ville de paris
à partir du xiiie siècle après
jésus-christ la construction de la ville
de paris s'accélère et le besoin de
matériaux de construction se fait sentir
on choisit donc d'élargir l'exploitation
des pierres aux souterrains de la
capitale c'est donc des sous sol
parisien que s'élèveront par exemple la
cathédrale notre dame de paris et le non
moins célèbre château du louvre
cette carrière se trouve sous un hôpital
l'hôpital l'actuel hôpital cochin
mais auparavant les terrains au dessus
dès le xviie siècles ont été occupées
par des capucins d'où ce mannequin qui
représente le les uns des moines
capucins qui pouvait éventuellement
vivre en surface setc capucins
lorsqu'ils sont venus ici ont découvert
alors s'ils sont venus dans les terres
en surface ont découvert qu'il avait des
carrières en dessous et on fait quelques
petites petite consolidation en pierre
sèche au xviie siècle et bien évidemment
lorsque l'inspection des carrières a été
créée à la fin du xviiie siècle
l'inspection à consolider le secteur
comme elle était en train de consulter
tout ce qu'il y avait dans paris et ami
d adapter les travaux a mis des plaques
gravées pour se repérer par rapport à la
surface
d'où par exemple cette indication tweet
service dans la première cour des
capucins un puits de service un puits
qui sert pour le service de l'inspection
des carrières effectivement se
positionne par rapport à la surface mais
c'est aussi très important d'avoir ce
genre d'inscription en dessous puisque
par exemple dans des courriers de
charlie axel 10 euros on va trouver des
indications telles que aller chercher
des terres pour combler la carrière on
allait chercher des matériaux pour faire
des consultations au pied du puy de
service de la première cour des capucins
donc il faut que les ouvriers car les
ouvriers de l'inspection des carrières
qui circuit en carrière qui font les
travaux en carrière il faut qu'ils
sachent à quel puis de service ils vont
trouver les matériaux dont ils ont
besoin
un numéro une initiale une année le
numéro indique le numéro d'ordre du
pilier qui a été créée par exemple cette
tiers provient d'un pilier qui était 21e
qui avait été édifiée sous l'inspectorat
delorieux en 1853 et pendant pendant la
révolution française
par exemple on voit là bas 14 b 4 r
pendant la révolution française on s'est
mis à compter à partir de 1792 en année
républicaine dont par exemple la pierre
qui est au fond c'est à 14e
elle est extraite d'un pilier qui était
14e fête sous brasles pendant la
quatrième année de la république
en 1777 la sélection des carrières et
crée en 1729 50 ans avant on a pour la
première fois l'idée de mettre aux
encoignures des rues les noms que l'on
avait déjà reporté sur des plans mais on
n'avait pas eu l'idée de les mettre dans
les rues donc pour se déplacer les
personnes étaient obligés de demander à
d'autres individus qu'il croisait dans
la rue où se trouve-t-elle rue parce que
c'était pas marquer donc 10 729 on met
au champagne ont des maisons les noms de
rues donc en 1779 le premier système de
numérotage qu'on a créés c'est un
système dit de choc en retour on partait
d'une extrémité de la rue 1 2 3 4 5 et
pas de séparation père un père est
arrivé à l'autre extrémité 11 12 par
contre à verser 13 14 15 et on
descendait donc on avait le plus grand
numéro en face du plus petit donc c'est
un système donc dit deux chocs en retour
mais comme il a été créé en 1779 que
c'est encore la royauté à cette époque
là en 1791
on a voulu abolir tous qu'il est de la
royauté et on a supprimé ce système est
ce qui fait qu'on a créé en 1805 le
système de numérotage actuelle qui est
père un père séparé on a pris la
référence comme référence la scène les
rues qui était perpendiculaire à la
scène
on a fait une croissance des numéros en
s'éloignant de la scène puisque tu as
grandi la ville par les faubourgs et
pour les rues qui sont parallèles à la
scène on a choisi arbitrairement le sens
du courant comme le sens d'accroissement
des numéros et ses rues par la la c'est
donc un sens d'accroissement en suivant
le courant et 7 fonctionne tellement
bien que versailles qui a été numérotées
peu de temps après on a décidé de
l'avenue de paris ce sera comme la scène
on sait référencés par rapport à la mi
temps
on a des petits dessins comme ici un
oiseau qui a un rameau de éventuellement
on va dire d'olivier dans le bec
mais surtout ce qui est important c'est
que le bec et diriger vers un puit et il
était de tradition semble-t-il que des
oiseaux soient dessinés pour indiquer
aux ouvriers le chemin pas de la liberté
mais le chemin du retour à la surface le
chemin de de la pause le chemin de du
repos après un travail de duos et
laborieux sachant que bien évidemment
toutes ces galeries n'était pas éclairé
avec autant lumière qu'on peut les
parcourir maintenant c'était on éclaire
est avec une chandelle que l'endroit où
l'on était donc on avait un petit halo
lumineux
les ouvriers ne voyait pratiquement
jamais le jour surtout en hiver il
descendait il faisait nuit encore nuit
de remonter il est aujourd'hui c'est ab
denis cochin avait remarqué que les
ouvriers carrier de l'inspection des
carrières quand il avait un accident on
les remonter en surface bien évidemment
on essayait de transportée à
l'hôtel-dieu qui était un kilomètre
d'ici et cette distance d'un kilomètre
était trop longue et certains plus
ouvrier n'arrivait pas vivant à l'hôtel
dieu et donc il a eu l'idée
l'abbé joël denis cochin d'acheter en
1780 trois maisons entourées de terrain
aux capucins sur lesquels il a fait
bâtir ce qui va devenir l'hôpital cochin
ces travaux ont duré jusqu'en 1792 donc
ici nous sommes en pleine date de
consolidation au moment des travaux du
futur hôpital cochin 1782 c'est
l'inauguration de l'hôpital qui
deviendra cochin par la suite et l'abbé
ne gèlent de nico chat ne survivra 15
ans à son oeuvre puisque il décédera lui
en 1783 on découvre deux autres
inscriptions historiquement intéressante
rue de la bourbe aux côtés du nord donc
sous le trottoir nord de la rue de la
bourde qui est devenu le
le boulevard de port royal et nous
voyons aussi un numéro 2 163 en fait
nous sommes sur le même côté que le
numéro deux cent soixante dix où on a vu
une fleur de lys qui a survécu
miraculeusement
et ici même si on remettait du noir
animal dans cette forme qui ai gratté on
ne retrouverait pas la fleur de lys
cette fleur de lys c'est parti de là des
150 à peu près clients ont été retrouvés
pendant la révolution française et donc
gratter puisqu'un décret demandé à
partir de 1793 de détruire tous ces
symboles séditieux de la royauté mais il
ya aussi des plats grave et qui
rappellent des rues qui ont pu
disparaître par exemple ici nous sommes
rue des capucins côté du midi donc sous
le trottoir sud
mais cette rue des capucins a été
englobée dans l'hôpital cochin et
n'existent plus en surface et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que on a créé
ce qu'on appelle la doublure
topographique du paris du xviiie siècle
par exemple on voit rue de seine côté du
midi il existe effectivement toujours
une rue de seine à paris mais cette
plaque vient du réseau du jardin des
plantes et c'est elle était sous la rue
qui est devenu de nos jours la rue
cuvier et l'intérêt un désintérêt des
sous sols de paris c'est d'avoir des
plaques de rues qui rappelle la
topographie du xviiie siècle et d'avoir
plein de vestiges qui rappellent des
décisions administratives qui ont été
prises bien évidemment surface mais qui
ont été appelés à appliquer sous terre
tels que la numérotation des rues telles
que la création du calendrier
républicain tel que la création du
système métrique tout ça on retrouve
figé en carrière puisque on l'a gravé
dans la pierre j'allais dire pour
l'éternité
oh
notre visite des souterrains parisiens
s'achèvent ici nous remontons vers la
surface en laissant derrière nous
les mystères de paris
le mans
le
nous
nous
je